BARBARA IMPERIALI:
OK, I want to walk us
through a bit of an
exercise to understand
what happens when people become
resistant to an antibiotic.
What's the molecular
basis for resistance?
It's nothing magical.
It's really things
that you can understand
based on what you've
learned during various parts
of the course.
But I just want to remind you
about this dreadful schematic
here, which shows how
rapidly resistance
emerges to different antibiotics
by showing you the year
that the drugs are introduced
and the year that resistances
develop.
One of the newest antibiotics
to be introduced--
people thought, oh, it's a
different mechanism of action.
It should be pretty resilient.
It should last for a while.
It should be useful
with daptomycin.
It's a cyclic
peptide antibiotic,
which has a particular
structure that doesn't
look like a lot of the others.
And honestly, it was
two to three years
before resistance emerged.
So what I want to
do is think together
about what are the ways in
which a bacterium could evolve
to develop resistance
against an antibiotic?
So here we've got the target.
We know that the
antibiotic is very
effective against the target.
What types of things could
happen in the bacterium
to make it manage to just
ignore the antibiotic
and resist the antibiotic?
Any suggestions?
So it's very simple.
There's a molecular target.
It could be topoisomerase.
It could be in fact the
ribosome and the machinery
for synthesizing proteins.
It could be the machinery that
cross-links peptidoglycan.
What sorts of approaches
and what sorts of strategies
might evolve to make that
antibiotic stop working?
OK, fire.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When two
hydrogen-holding enzymes
at-- create things that are
not [INAUDIBLE] absorbing.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: OK, right.
So antibiotic gets in.
The enzyme breaks up the
antibiotic, so evolution
to destroy the antibiotic.
And that's very much what
happens with penicillin.
The key aspect of the
structure that's so useful
suddenly becomes invalidated
through a degradation
of the beta-lactam bond.
So that's one of them.
What's next?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
Ah, so maybe there
could be uptake decreased,
so that's quite hard,
but there could be some
evolution of the cell wall
to make it less permeable
to the antibiotic
because we're usually relying
on antibiotics to diffuse
in passively.
So if the membrane--
this could be in a membrane
of a Gram-negative bacterium,
or the outer membrane of a
Gram-negative bacterium that
has a slightly
different composition,
could physically
change its structure.
These are tough things
to evolve all at once,
but it's certainly
a possibility.
We've talked about uptake.
What about-- what
else could happen?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you
get a [INAUDIBLE] out,
such that they have
oxygen [INAUDIBLE]..
BARBARA IMPERIALI: OK.
So this guy could just--
we've got a circular
antibiotic usually,
but this just changes--
the target just changes.
It can't bind anymore,
through mutation,
so that the antibiotic
simply doesn't bind.
It gets in, but it's changed,
and that happens a lot.
It also happens a lot--
one can think of
antibiotic resistance
very much along the same veins
as one thinks of resistance
to chemotherapeutic agents.
You're targeting a kinase.
Your drug works great.
A year later, the
cancer comes back
because there's a single
mutation in your target.
This happens a lot with the
EGF, kinase, RAS's and so on.
There's a dramatic change.
So this change would be
a change in the target.
You mentioned two things, right?
I thought.
Maybe not.
AUDIENCE: Well,
like I said, there
were some for that [INAUDIBLE].
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Ah.
On the surface.
AUDIENCE: A couple of days
you're going back, so.
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
OK, so there could be
some kind of import strategy.
So some antibiotics
just diffuse.
Some go in through
targeted import,
and that might change so
that the antibiotic can't
get in anymore.
Other thoughts?
There's a couple of
other sneaky ways.
I mean, you've got to sort
of give these bacteria credit
for maximum sneakiness.
So if influx is an
issue, what about efflux?
The biggest problem
with antibiotics
against Gram-negatives is
that they way upregulate
efflux pumps.
They just, like, cover their
cells with pumps that just go,
you're going to give
me an antibiotic?
I'm just going to lob it
straight back out to you.
So the efflux pumps increase.
So their molecules, we
have a lot of efflux pumps
to just kick out
things that are not--
that we don't want in our cells.
The bacteria have
similar things.
They will-- they're
fairly promiscuous,
exporting pumps that
will bind to things
that don't look like things
that should be in a cell,
and literally bind to them on
the inside of the membrane,
[MAKES SQUIRT SOUND]
send them back
to the outside of the membrane.
So Gram-negative
bacteria can massively
upregulate the
production of a pump
that they already have, but they
just make much more of them.
So in many cases, you can
hardly test a new compound
because it's getting pumped out
as fast as it gets pumped in.
What could be a strategy
when this happens?
Because people are doing this.
You inhibit the pump.
So you make your antibiotic--
it works great, but you
stop the pump working.
So you have to give two
drugs, the drug that's
the antibiotic to the target
and the drug that inhibits
the pump, and that happens.
Similarly, with this mechanism,
where the antibiotic gets
destroyed, you can
recover from this
by inhibiting the
destroying enzyme,
and then your antibiotic
doesn't get destroyed
when it gets into the cells.
So there's one extremely
important formulation
of antibiotic that is used.
It's called Augmentin.
And what it is is
a penicillin plus
a beta-lactamase inhibitor.
It's the drug that
works plus a drug that
inhibits the enzyme
that destroys the drug.
People get this all the time.
Every day of the week,
this stuff is prescribed.
It's a two-compound
cocktail that
has something to overcome the
resistance so that your drug
still works in a cell.
All right?
And there's one
more key mechanism,
and what bacteria will just do
is they say, well, you know,
I'm getting dosed with
this much antibiotic.
What's a good way around it
is to massively upregulate
the biosynthesis of the target
to a state where you just
can't saturate it all.
So upregulation of the target
is a very, very common thing.
So you-- this should have
just increased the number
of transcripts being made.
You increase the amount
of target being made so
that, even if antibiotics
are flooding into cells,
there's just not enough to
inhibit all of the target
because it's been upregulated
by 10 or 100-fold.
So what I think is cool
about all these mechanisms
is they all make sense.
You just kind of have
to think of them--
do I stop the drug getting in?
Do I stop it getting pumped out?
Do I stop it getting degraded?
Do I make more target?
All of those things
are very viable,
and they are strategies that
are used quite commonly.
So very commonly, both in
bacteria and in viruses,
we seldom give one compound.
We commonly give
multiple compounds
to sort of hit multiple
targets, because if you
gave a two-drug
cocktail to a bacterium,
but you knew there was going
to be upregulation of a target,
you could hope that the other
enzyme is still a target.
So you give cocktails of drugs,
as opposed to single drugs.
And you're going to see
that very relevantly when
we talk about the HIV
virus because it's only
been that HIV has become--
HIV-AIDS has become
a treatable condition
because of drug cocktails, not
because of singular drugs that
inhibit one step.
And you'll see it very,
very commonly there.
Any questions about this stuff?
OK.
So we're going to
move on to viruses.
And so I will actually update
the slides that are on the web
to give you this
set of information
so you can see it in one place.
OK, viruses.
Viruses are
fascinating organisms.
They don't have the
right to be alive
because they don't have
the machinery to be alive,
but they exploit the
host's mechanisms
for completing their viability.
So viruses, more
or less, I think
we like to think of them
as living a borrowed life.
And they only survive
if they have spent
some time inside a host cell.
So we will see with viruses,
some viruses specifically
target humans.
Other viruses may spend some
time in different organisms,
and then target humans,
and be carried around
amongst different organisms.
But the key thing is
that viruses can only
actually replicate once
they're inside a host cell
because they basically
exploit all of the host cell's
machinery to do that.
So viruses don't make
many of their own enzymes.
They don't have their
own amino acid supplies
or all the metabolic
enzymes that
are required for life, all the
replication, transcription,
translation machinery.
They just borrow the
host's machinery,
but there are occasionally
individual components
that the virus will
bring along with it
to cover certain things that
are not provided by the hosts.
But viral genomes are tiny.
They may comprise
maybe eight genes.
Some of them are a
lot-- are bigger,
but they are very,
very small genomes.
They're very, what we
call, parsimonious genomes,
so there's overlapping
genes, so you can keep
the genome tiny by having--
compacting the
size of the genome.
And then there are
bigger viruses.
Some of the biggest viruses
approach the sizes of bacteria,
like the mimiviruses,
and they may
have been an intermediate
step from virus
to more elaborated organisms.
And those viruses have
a bit more machinery
within their contexts.
People-- obviously, there's
no fossil record for viruses.
It's not like we can go,
you know, go exploring
and find a fossil record.
But where these
viruses are being found
is in the permafrost,
so they're frozen.
They've been frozen
there for centuries.
So people are finding
really sort of scary things
in the Siberian permafrost
because the viruses are
preserved there.
And some of these
giant viruses are being
discovered in those locations.
And if that's not the subject
for wonderful sci-fi books,
I don't know what is,
because there are-- and I
tend to read those things
because my favorite thing is
finding mistakes in them.
So there's a lot out there
about those kinds of things.
So let me just show
you a tiny bit about--
you know, this is that boring
old "learn genetics" thing
right from the beginning, but
what I want to take you back to
is sizes.
So we know all this stuff.
We've learned it to death,
hemoglobin, antibodies,
and ribosome.
But what I really want to
point out on this slide is that
the smallest viruses,
like the rhinovirus--
that's the common cold--
or the hepatitis virus
are not barely any bigger
than the ribosome.
So obviously, there's
not much in the virus,
but all the components
of the virus
have evolved to enable them to
sneakily get into host cells,
exploit the host cell
machinery, and then replicate
inside host cell, and then
get out of the host cell
and ready to infect
another host cell.
So I want you to really
notice these sizes.
So the rhinovirus is
similar to a ribosome,
but some viruses, which
we will talk about,
the influenza virus and the
HIV virus are a little bigger,
but none of them compete up
to the size of a bacterium.
And just to get you into that
mode, there are the bacteria,
and there's the
mitochondria, and remember
endosymbiotic theory, bacteria,
similar size to mitochondria,
and much, much bigger
than any typical virus.
But giant viruses approach
some of these bigger sizes.
They're a different
ballgame altogether.
And we won't talk about
them, apart from the fact
that they're really cool, and
they're in the permafrost.
All right, so another
impressive thing
about viruses, as they look--
some of them like this.
Phage, a bacterial virus,
they look like things,
lunar landers, for example, or
sort of other kinds of things.
Some of them are linear.
Some of them are
different kinds of shapes.
A lot of viruses are icosahedra.
We'll talk about
that in a moment.
But the fact sheet about
viruses is first of all sizes.
And the typical viral size,
if there is something typical,
expand from 20 to 400
nanometers in diameter.
So remember, the
ribosome sits right
at this end with respect
to size, but bacteria--
oh, yellow, I can't do
a yellow lecture here--
remember, are 1 to 10
micrometers in length,
depending on what
dimension you're measuring,
so considerably smaller,
nanometer scale,
micrometer scale for bacteria.
So that's the first thing
that it's important to know.
They're very small.
The next critical thing
is what's in a virus?
What is its-- what's the
blood and guts of a virus?
And it's either
DNA or RNA, and it
can be single-stranded
or double-stranded.
So it has its genetic material.
Its genetic material
is usually dedicated
to making more copies of itself.
So if the virus has a
coat, a coat of proteins,
the virus has to
have a gene for that
because the host isn't going
to have a coat for a virus.
So the virus has to have
certain specialized things that
complete itself that can't be
borrowed from the host cell.
And they can be--
let's see-- they can be what
are called capsid viruses
or enveloped.
Capsid viruses just
have a protein coat.
The enveloped viruses have
a membrane surrounding them
with proteins stuck into them.
So the enveloped viruses
have an outer membrane
which is studded with proteins.
But what is cool
about the virus is
it never makes
its own membranes.
It doesn't make
its phospholipids.
It just, as it emerges
from a host cell,
pinches a piece of
the cell surface.
It steals the cellular
membrane with it,
as it's emerging from a cell.
And you'll see this in
a video, how cool that
is, all the proteins that--
all the components of the virus
cluster near the
surface of a membrane,
and then you have this
wonderful endocytosis
using the host membrane.
So the virus never has
to make it own membrane.
And not all viruses are
enveloped, just some of them,
and you'll see examples of each.
So the definition
really is that they're
small, infectious
agents, that they only
replicate inside living
cells because they
have to exploit a lot of the
machinery of living cells.
And they can infect
humans, other animals.
There are plant viruses.
Bacteria have viruses.
So all living organisms have
viruses that infect them.
But viruses are usually targeted
very specifically to the cells
that they infect.
And, in fact, you
will see with HIV,
it's not just a virus
that infects a human host.
It infects
specifically, and that
was why it was so terrifying,
this-- actually T cells.
That's the one cell type in
the host that it goes after.
So viruses very often
target to particular organs
within their hosts,
and that's why
we know some of the viruses.
And you'll see that the
names of the viruses
are related to the organs
that they may infect.
So I want to just briefly
describe the terms.
We talk about these with
all infectious diseases,
that they may be endemic,
epidemic, and pandemic.
Endemic is the term
that we use for, there's
a very low level of
an infectious agent
in the population.
It's completely out of--
within control.
There's a few cases,
but there's not
a transfer from person to
person or animal to animal.
We would call that endemic, a
very, very low level of virus
that doesn't cause any threat.
As soon as the virus or
bacterial infectious agents
starts spreading amongst
a local population,
we would call that
a local epidemic, so
all of a community,
all of a country,
so very much defined
geographically
into a particular space where
there's transmission of viruses
from person to person or animal
to person within a community.
There has to be direct contact.
But now, with
travel, many viruses
reach pandemic stages,
which means worldwide.
So plane travel really
caused enormous trouble
because you can have a
virus in Africa or Asia.
Somebody gets on a plane
and ends up somewhere else,
and the virus has been
moved to a new country.
I made the terrible mistake of
reading Hot Zone on a plane one
time, which is about
Marburg virus, which
is where people basically just
start bleeding out in the spot.
And I'm reading
this book, and it's
describing the
steps of someone who
had Marburg and was just sort
of bleeding out next to them
on the plane.
And I'm like, are you crazy,
reading this book on a plane?
Because they were describing
how Marburg was just
moved from its country of
origin to New York City,
or something like that.
So you remember when we
had the Ebola concerns.
There was a real,
genuine worry that Ebola
would jump through
flight travel,
through people coming
in at airports,
and end up with a
pandemic of Ebola.
When there was a real problem
with the avian flu in Asia,
Singapore, that's very, very
protective of its territory,
had sensors that would--
you would go into Singapore,
and you'd go down these
two huge escalators.
And they had sensors
measuring people's temperature
at a distance as they came
down the escalator, and hauling
people over, and sort
of interrogating them,
where have you been?--
to see whether they would be
allowed to enter Singapore,
because the flight travel,
people getting on planes,
spreading a very contagious
virus to a new country
is very, very realistic.
The issue with spreading
to pandemic situations
is very, very important
when one thinks of history,
because when the Europeans
were conquering the Americas,
in particular South America
and Central America,
they brought with
them a lot of viruses.
But there was an innate
sort of resistance
to-- because of years
and years of exposure.
But these communities have
never seen these viruses,
so millions of people died
because they were suddenly
exposed to a human virus that
they had never seen before,
through transmission from a
country where there wasn't
such a problem with the virus.
So the indigenous peoples
of the Americas, Australia,
and New Zealand had
terrible consequences there.
Some of you have probably
heard of the Spanish flu,
and that was towards the
tail end of World War I
and is thought to have killed
as many as 100 million people.
And that, in fact,
is quite interesting.
It's called the Spanish flu,
but there's some evidence
that it might have
originated in the Americas,
in the boats that took
troops over to Europe
to help at the tail end
of the First World War.
And there's a really interesting
book about that whole story,
that the Spanish flu may not
have originated in Spain.
And that's a-- it's
definitely a worthwhile read.
So that tells you a lot about
the statistics of viruses.
I just want to highlight
here, we talk about HIV
as a very serious virus.
It emerged in the early
'80s to this current--
well, in 2011, there were
35 million people infected.
There's about 2 and 1/2
million new cases a year.
But what's fascinating
about HIV--
there was a stage before
the really good antivirals
were available that,
if the mother had HIV,
the baby would get HIV.
But now, if there's
treatment of the mother,
and the baby is delivered,
often by a Caesarean section,
the baby can escape
being infected
with the virus due to
the new antivirals.
So that's really
important, that the--
originally, there were a
lot of cases of newborns who
simply got HIV during birth.
But now that can be--
there's escape from that,
which is really, really cool.
The viral load can
be brought really low
with the common
antivirals against HIV,
and that next generation
doesn't have that sentence.
So I mentioned to you
that a lot of viruses
are basically named after
the organs that they hit.
So I've just got
a human being here
with a lot of different viruses
that hit different places,
and I just want to
point out a few points.
Viruses may be targets nowadays
of childhood vaccinations,
and many of you--
I hope all of you--
have had vaccinations to
many of these common viruses.
There is a concern now with
communities that are deciding
not to vaccinate children.
That's a huge social problem
that may, initially, sort of,
people can get away
with it because there's
community vaccination.
You're in a community
where a lot of people
have a resistance or some
sort of immunity to a virus.
But as communities become
less and less vaccinated,
than later
generations will start
to get the disease seriously.
And that's actually happening
in parts of the world where
there's--
there used to be no
polio, and now there's
polio emerging because
the community immunity has
been-- is fading away.
So we hope that
people get vaccinated.
That's for sure.
The vaccinations work.
Several vaccinations--
several viruses
were pretty much eradicated.
Smallpox and polio were two
of the real poster examples
of childhood
vaccinations that worked
and worked amazingly well.
But now, there's a
problem with failure
to vaccinate in certain
parts of the world.
So that's a concern.
And then, another interesting
thing is that some viruses--
whoops, oops, go back.
Sorry.
Go back, back, back, back.
Don't now-- that's all a secret.
You can't see that just yet.
Some viruses lead to cancer,
so human papilloma virus,
where there is a vaccine,
the people who have HIV--
some of the types of
hepatitis and Epstein-Barr
are all associated with
later cases of cancer.
That's important to know.
So often cancers are named by
the organ that they attach,
so even though the three--
the five hepatitises all attack
the liver, they're not related.
They're just five viruses
that go off to the liver.
So if you've had a
vaccination against Hep A,
It doesn't protect you from
Hep B or C by a relationship.
They're very, very
different, so you have
to have different vaccinations.
So this just gives you a
nice view of human viruses,
what their names are, what
organs they may attack,
what sorts of things they
might be associated with.
But the trouble is, this
nomenclature doesn't get you
anywhere towards understanding
the mechanism of a virus.
So what we will focus on
is a much better system
for describing
viruses that's based
on whether they have DNA
or RNA within the genomes
that they import
into host cells,
and whether that DNA or
RNA is single-stranded or
double-stranded, because
that truly tells us
a lot more about the virus
and maybe the steps that
could be inhibited to
prevent the viral infections.
But first of all,
just a few pictures--
here's some-- so viruses
can be rod-shaped.
They can look like--
they can be icosahedra.
They can just have a capsid.
So I mentioned they
may just have a protein
coat, the sets of
repeating proteins that
pack into a beautiful structure,
very commonly an icosahedron,
and I'll show you why that is.
Or they may be
enveloped viruses,
like, influenza has a
membranous surface around where
the DNA is packaged.
All of these have nucleic
acids packaged within them,
DNA or RNA, single
or double-stranded.
And in the case of
the enveloped viruses,
that membrane-- it's
a normal membrane.
It's just like your membrane.
In fact, it is your membrane--
will have proteins
dotted within it
that's actually-- serve as
recognition to the host cells.
They'll grab onto host cells and
be the source of the infection
into the host cells.
And this is a bacterial
virus, and as I said,
I just love the way they--
I mean, they really
look like this.
You know, the cartoon
is really the cartoon
of what the thing looks
like, and they're sort of
pretty amazing.
And they kind of--
they keep their nucleic
acid in the head here.
They land on their sort of feet,
and they shoot the nucleic acid
material into the host cells.
So that's very interesting.
Of course, this thing is--
OK.
So why are many viruses that
are capsid viruses icosahedra?
So it ends up being a
problem of geometry.
So how can you make a
perfect coat around something
with very, very few building
blocks of different types?
Like, if every building block
in that coat was different,
the virus would have to
have genes for all of them.
What viruses can
do is they can have
genes for, like, three pieces
of a module of the virus.
So I'm going to show you
how these capsid viruses get
assembled.
So here, color-coded,
is an icosahedral virus,
where I've coded in the
red, green, and blue,
a triangular component--
this is really cool--
that is a single sort of panel
on that icosahedral virus that
comes together as
a triangle through
noncovalent interactions
between three proteins.
You see that panel there.
What you can then do is
see how that panel would
fit into a pentagon with an
extra triangle stuck onto it,
and you can fit that
triangle into the pentagon
and also into the
additional piece.
And then you can
start to visualize
how you could build an
icosahedron from those pieces
because they represent each of
those faces within the virus.
So you can go from this, which
is a set of building blocks
that I just showed you--
then you can assemble
them like this.
And one of these would be
this part of the icosahedron,
and then you just have
a bunch of copies of it.
And you can see how you
would assemble that.
And years ago, I decided to
decorate my Christmas tree
with icosahedra.
So I went through this
geometrical thing,
and believe me, it
works really nicely.
You can put together
an icosahedron
and build an icosahedron.
You could spray it gold and
put it on your Christmas tree.
It's kind of fanatical,
but it really-- it's
highly recommended.
All right, so let's now get down
to something a little bit more
serious than Christmas
trees and things.
All right, so I told you that
the classification of viruses
by what organ they attack or
who discovered them or anything
is just--
is a vagary that's not so
useful to the non-physicians
because you can't
immediately know,
oh, this is how the virus
gets into the host cell.
This is how the virus
uses its genetic material
to make new viruses.
So what was developed
by Baltimore--
David Baltimore used to be at--
it was kind of interesting.
David Baltimore, a very famous
person and Nobel laureate,
used to be at MIT
when I was at Caltech,
and we moved in
opposite directions.
I'm not sure it was a
great trade for MIT,
but it was a great
trade for Caltech.
So I ended up with David
Baltimore's labs in Building 68
because we did that swap in
1999 or something like that.
So I thought that was
pretty interesting.
Anyway, so what
Baltimore decided
is-- was much better
to classify viruses
by the type of genetic material,
like, are they DNA or RNA?
Is that DNA or RNA
single-stranded or
double-stranded?
Because, depending on what the
genetic material in the virus
is, once that gets
unloaded into a host cell,
certain steps have to happen
in order for the virus
to be able to replicate
that genetic material,
to convert it ultimately
into the proteins
it needs, and then to package
up new viral genetic material
into viral capsids
so that they can then
be sprung out of the cell
and go infect another cell.
So the classification
basically went this way.
So if you think of it, what the
major goal in the infected cell
is to get the virus to a
stage where the virus has
plus-messenger RNA.
It has RNA that can be read
by the host's ribosomes
and convert it into proteins.
So the overall
goal of the virus,
if we give it sort of some
conscience, shall we say,
is to make its viral
material into messenger RNA.
Now, the virus doesn't
include messenger RNA.
That's just what is
made transiently,
but the virus may have
single-stranded DNA.
It may have plus-sense RNA.
It may have negative-sense RNA.
It could have
double-stranded DNA,
or it could even have
double-stranded RNA.
And depending on what
that genetic material,
is what the Baltimore
classification of a virus
would be.
So depending on what's
inside the virus,
then they can be classified.
And what we're going to go
through today and on Friday
is examples of class I, class
V, and class VI viruses,
so we can see how that
genetic material ultimately
becomes a new viral--
a new virus within a host cell,
or at least the components
thereof ready to be
sprung out of a virus.
And there's one important point
that I want to also address--
oops-- budding or lytic.
All right, there are
two ways in which
viruses escape their host cell.
They may be budding.
So here you have a host cell.
The viral components
all congregate
near the surface of the
membrane from the inside,
and then the host cell buds off.
The viral components go with
it, and the bud splits off.
So the host cell
has its nucleus.
It's still intact.
HIV is such a virus.
HIV doesn't kill its hosts.
That's the best
sign of a parasite.
It wants the host to stick
around, so it just buds off.
The other types of
viruses are lytic,
and, basically, the cell just
bursts open and throws out
the virus.
So they're in two categories.
Some of them are budding,
though the enveloped viruses
have to be budding
because they're
going to take with them the
membrane of the host cell.
All right?
So that's another
important difference.
So what have we got here?
So ultimately, the goal is to be
able to make a plus-strand mRNA
for protein synthesis.
So we really need to have the
appropriate sense of the RNA
that will dictate the
protein synthesis.
So let's first of all look at
one of the simple versions,
a double-stranded DNA virus.
And this is represented
by the smallpox virus.
So everybody's heard of
that, and herpes simplex.
And these are both
enveloped viruses,
so that means they
have a membrane shell.
And so I'm just
going to walk you
through the steps of going
from the double-stranded DNA
to make a new virus.
So here's the virus.
It has a capsid, as well
as a membrane envelope.
And there's recognition between
the virus and the host cell.
And we'll talk very specifically
about what that recognition is
when we talk about HIV, because
that's very well categorized.
Once the virus gets
into the host cell,
it sort of spills off
all the coat and dumps
out its double-stranded DNA, the
viral DNA, into the host cell.
And then that DNA can--
in the nucleus, can
replicate into more copies
of the viral DNA, or
it can be transcribed
into messenger
RNA, which is then
the coat for all those capsid
proteins that the virus needs.
And then these start to
self-assemble within the host
cell where the capsid
proteins wrap around
the viral genetic material.
They accumulate near
the surface of the cell,
and then they bud
off from the cell.
So that's how you
go from simple DNA.
So these processes
are completely
based on the human enzymes
that do those processes.
Replication, we've
got to replicate DNA.
We're going to have to
do that in the nucleus.
Transcription,
we're going to have
to ship out part of the DNA from
the nucleus to the cytoplasm
and make--
we're going to have to make
a copy of the messenger RNA
and ship it out to the nucleus.
And then we're going to use
the host ribosomes, the host's
amino acids, the building
blocks in everything,
to make a new protein that
is not a host's cell protein.
It's the capsid protein.
Obviously, the human
cell isn't going
to be making a capsid protein.
So that's the main thing
that the virus had to encode.
It had to have the
DNA to make that.
So that all looks
sort of fairly simple,
and the steps make sense.
This is why we cover this
virus first because it really--
it's kind of the most
transparent to understand,
so this transient stage of
sort of borrowing machinery.
And as I mentioned
here, the virus
can spring out of the host cell.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So all it means is--
one's that don't kill the host
cells, how do they, like, on the
body, or the cells that they--
BARBARA IMPERIALI: They start
to just be too much of a burden
onto the body, so they're just--
you know, if they're
inside cells and exploiting
the resources of the
cell, they're basically--
they're harming it, but they're
not destroying it instantly
every life cycle.
They're just using resources
to replicate, and then go--
get spread to another
cell, and another cell,
where they'll keep
using resources.
So it's really just an
overload of the system.
It's a very good point.
But they can stick
around a long time,
and with HIV,
you're going to see
what really sneaky
thing they do is
because they put their
genome into the host genome.
And that's sort of
really pretty terrifying.
I always ask this question,
but it's kind of a silly one.
You know, what is life?
A virus is alive.
Well, they're kind of alive,
but they're not really alive
unless they have
some place to live.
But aren't we all like that?
So that's very philosophical.
So we'll move right on here.
So when you think
of a virus, this
is the original
central dogma, all
the moving parts of
the central dogma.
And note-- so that when
you think of a virus,
what double-- what does
double-stranded DNA need
from the host?
It's got all of these things.
It's got the-- the host
has the polymerase.
It has the DNA-dependent
RNA polymerase.
It's got all the
ribosomal machinery.
So the only thing
that the virus needs
is the gene for its
capsid proteins.
So you can peel out from
that entire life cycle
the one unique thing
about the virus.
So that's a double-stranded DNA.
Let's now move to a
different type of V,
which is a
negative-stranded RNA virus.
And these are quite
important because these
form the basis for--
let me just go to the diseases.
This is the influenza
virus, and I'm
going to mention some
very important points
relative to influenza virus.
So influenza virus is what's
known as a segmented virus.
And what that means
is that its genome--
in this case, it's
negative-stranded RNA--
is in pieces.
A lot of other viruses just
have a single strand of genome,
a single nucleic acid strand.
So it's just one piece, where
portions of that nucleic acid
code for different
proteins, and they'll often
code for initially polyproteins
that get broken up.
And we'll see a virus
with a single strand
when we look at HIV.
But the influenza virus
has a segmented genome.
And that's very relevant
for its lifestyle
because we'll see in a moment
how influenza virus can cause
more damage than we anticipate
because of recombination
of different copies
of the segmented virus
through differences.
But let's first
of all take a look
at the life cycle of this
virus, and then we'll
move on to dealing with the
issue of the segmentation.
So here's a typical enveloped
virus with a capsid.
Inside, there's the
negative-stranded RNA that gets
into the host cell,
and you make--
and you dump into the host
cell the viral genomic RNA.
That can get copied.
The minus-strand RNA gets
copied to the plus-strand RNA,
which becomes the messenger for
protein synthesis in the cell.
So you've gone in
with minus strand.
You've made the plus strand,
which is the messenger,
and that encodes all
the proteins that
are needed for a new virus.
And some of those proteins
may have signal sequences.
They may be shipped to
the surface of the cell,
and they may be planted in
the outside cellular membrane
of the host cells.
And what you see here is
copies of those proteins
actually in the
surface of a cell.
So what happens with this
virus is, once all the moving
parts are made, they congregate
at the surface of a cell,
get packaged, and then
bud off from the cell.
So remember all the rules you
learned about where proteins
end up in the cell are
all good still here
because the capsid proteins
have to get to a cell membrane,
so they're translated
with a signal sequence.
They congregate-- I don't know
how this self-assembly occurs,
but it's a fascinating
process, so that ultimately you
bud off an intact virion
from the host cell.
But the key thing that
the virus has to have
is something that will
copy negative-stranded RNA
to plus-stranded RNA, which
is going to be the messenger.
So the virus also has to code
for a particular protein that's
unique to its lifestyle.
So it has an RA-dependent
RNA polymerase.
We don't use an
RNA-dependent RNA polymerase,
but the virus needs it to
take its negative-strand RNA
to a plus-strand RNA, which
will be the messenger.
So does that make sense?
So obviously,
that's a moving part
that it needs to
provide to the host.
Now, what's this about segmented
viruses that's quite important?
Oh, and I just want
to underscore here,
what defines the destination
of these proteins,
whether they're capsid
proteins or proteins that
are going to be packaged
within the virus,
is basically just
the same rules that
apply that we talked
about when we talked
about protein trafficking.
So every year,
there's a whole panic.
Did you get your flu shot?
Is it going to work this year?
Oh my god, millions of
people are going to get sick.
Go get your flu shot.
It's tetravalent, it's
trivalent, and so on.
So what we're trying
to do every year
is predict what the virus
is going to look like.
So we have to--
there are teams of people,
who sometimes get it wrong,
who predict the
variation in these genes.
And they look at winter in
the Southern Hemisphere,
because that
precedes us, and try
to guess what's going to happen
in winter in the Northern
Hemisphere.
And we get to try and put
together a vaccination package.
But the problem with the
viral influenza virus
is that there can be not
just a drift, like mutations,
small mutations happening
a little bit at a time,
but there can be
recombination of the genes,
because they are segmented,
into totally new virus particles
that have different properties.
So viruses don't just drift
in their genomic sequence.
They can have dramatic shifts
in their sequences that occur--
whoops-- through combinations
of viruses that come-- that
have infected different animals.
So some of the
common strains, when
we talk about certain strains
that have been very, very
troublesome to humans, may
result from such a combination.
So this would be the Eurasian
pig flu, the classic pig flu,
the human flu, the bird flu.
If, in certain communities
where people often
live with their
livestock, a cell
gets infected with
viruses, a human virus
and the swine virus, they
can mix and match together.
And you can make a totally
different viral composition,
where you've got one piece
of genetic information
from the swine flu and seven
more from the human flu.
And what that can
suddenly mean is
that the-- first of all, the
vaccines don't work at all,
but that they may have very,
very different properties
for infectivity.
The protein that is
expressed that may cause
that very first attack of
the virus on your cells
in the upper lungs may be
very different to the type--
to the protein that
comes from the swine flu
and may give you much more
serious lung infections
because they can go
deeper into the lungs.
So it can be very small
changes by pulling
an enzyme, a piece of gene, from
a completely different organism
and matching it up with
the rest of the genes
from the human virus that
makes for dramatic shifts
in viral infections
that cause these sorts
of sudden tectonic
shifts where we've really
got to deal with a virus.
There are two terms up here.
There's H and N. These
are hemagglutinin and
neuraminidase.
They are two proteins that
are in the viral coat,
so you'll often hear viruses
referred to as H1N1, H3N3,
and it's just the variant
of those proteins that
are in the viruses.
See these little terms here--
that's what that means,
what type of hemagglutinin,
what type of neuraminidase, is
on the surface of the virus.
So I am done for
today, and next class
will be exclusively about the
AIDS-HIV virus, where we'll
go into that life
cycle and also talk
about resistance to therapeutic
agents and combination
therapies.